17 février 2011
après la tunisie l'egypte la libye et
gagné à son tour par l'atmosphère
révolutionnaire du printemps arabe les
libyens veulent se libérer de
l'autoritarisme du colonel kadhafi au
pouvoir depuis 42 ans
la fronde s'étend rapidement à l'est de
tripoli notamment à benghazi fief
historique des révolte libyenne
la police tire à balles réelles sur la
population
la contestation gagne la capitale à
tripoli les coups de feu et les
incendies ont repris avec la nuit alors
que la capitale était plutôt fidèles au
colonel kadhafi
après trois jours de combats sanglants
l'est commencent à se libérer
kadhafi réaffirme sa volonté de rester
au pouvoir
brandissant son livre vert son célèbre
guide révolutionnaire
ils menacent sont mario nous n'avons pas
encore utilisé la force on à jane
richard libre et la force c'est celle du
peuple
il a aidé à battre s'il le faut je
l'utiliserai selon la loi internationale
et selon la constitution libyenne
à tripoli le dictateur est sans pitié
les tirs d'aviation des milices et des
snipers frappe la population
ce sont des mercenaires ils tuent des
gens dans la rue ils ne font aucune
distinction
les massacres sont désormais filmées par
les médias internationaux arrivés sur
place ils montrent un pays détruit par
la guerre
ça c'est le sens des jeunes qui ont fait
la révolution c'est le sang des martyrs
les hommes libres nos enfants le colonel
fait bombarder benghazi
parmi les victimes des civils des
enfants
leurs visages deviennent le symbole de
la folie meurtrière du dictateur toutes
les balles ont été tirées dans la
poitrine dans le coup et dans la tête
strappé
le 27 février le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu réagi embargo sur les armes gel
des avoirs financiers et saisine de la
cour pénale internationale pour enquêter
sur la répression meurtrière kadhafi
s'acharnent ils envoient des mercenaires
reconquérir l'est du pays kadhafi est un
boucher il tue des innocents et une aux
jeunes le 18 mars le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu autorise le lancement d'une
offensive aérienne pour stopper kadhafi
les etats unis la france et la
grande-bretagne mène une action
conjointe
[Musique]
sans maroc parce que c'est l'appât de la
bataille
pas exactement le colonel kadhafi se
battra jusqu'à sa mort le 20 octobre
2011 date à laquelle il est capturé et
tué par la rébellion
[Musique]